bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
l'espagne en bien de voir qu'ils
espèrent donc entrer dans le cercle très
réservé en des pays producteurs de
vaccins on imagine qu'en tant que
médecin vous n'attendais que ça oui
l'espagne ne bouderai pas son plaisir à
rentrer dans la cour des grands qui
disposent de leurs propres vaccins et là
on pense évidemment à l' aventure de
valve déjà en france qui n'avait pas
retenu l'attention des pouvoirs publics
dès le début et qui était tombé dans le
giron anglais et bien l'espagne ne veut
surtout pas aujourd'hui suivre l'exemple
de valve neva et suit de très près
effectivement cet espoir que donne
aujourd'hui le laboratoire ils prat
quelle fiabilité peut-on accorder à ce
laboratoire dont qui développe
habituellement des vaccins pour les
animaux alors écoutez d'abord il faut il
faut rappeler que l'épidémie du
coronavirus correspond à ce qu'on
appelle une zoonose une anthroposophes
en rose c'est à dire une maladie animale
à transmission humaine et c'est vrai que
dans ce cadre les laboratoires de santé
animale présente un intérêt tout
particulier je rappeler dans ce cadre
effectivement que par exemple en france
meirieu est le deuxième laboratoire
mondial de santé animale et contribue
fortement au développement de solutions
en santé humaine et vous savez c'est
quelque chose qui est relativement
récent qui a été repris au niveau
mondial par effectivement cette notion
de one health c'est à dire une santé
unique pour les animaux les êtres
humains et l'environnement et donc c'est
vrai que oui oui je vous en prie donc
c'est vrai que l'idée qu'à raqqa
laboratoire de santé animale puisse
participer et puissent contribuer à
l'élaboration d'un vaccin pour la santé
humaine est loin d'être farfelue
alors il pourrait s'agir du premier
vaccin anti copie entièrement conçu et
fabriqué en europe c'est un défi
scientifique mais on imagine
si économique face aux deux géants au
géant pfizer
oui effectivement c'est un c'est un
énorme défi économique surtout que hypra
n'est quand même pas un gros laboratoire
même si c'est vrai qu'il représente
environ 200 millions de chiffre
d'affaires par an mais aujourd'hui il a
le soutien de l'état espagnol et ses
sites qui peut lui permettre d'espérer
de mener à bien à la fois les études
nécessaires pour prouver l'innocuité et
l'efficacité des vaccins et pour ensuite
envisager la commercialisation de ce
vaccin
alors philippe emmanuel dit il s'agit
d'un vaccin dit classique c'est-à-dire
qu'il contient le virus atténué ducobu
de 19 il est comparable aujourd'hui à
quel vaccin
oui alors non justement les deux
forme de vaccins qui sont retenus par
hypra sont les deux mêmes formes de
vaccins que sanofi en france c'est à
dire d'une part une protéine
recombinante
en gros c'est un morceau de virus mais
artificielle qui est reproduit qui
permet de générer des anticorps contre
cette protéine qui effectivement est un
morceau de virus mais par contre ce
n'est pas un virus
ça n'est pas un vaccin à virus vivant
atténué ça n'est pas non plus avec sa
adénovirus comme celui d'astrazeneca et
donc il ya ce premier vaccin à protéines
recombinantes et il y a également un
deuxième vaccin qui est celui à arn
messagers également donc ça veut dire a
priori que les problèmes qu'il a eus
autour d'astra zeneca notamment et
johnson & johnson ne vont pas se
retrouver sur ce vaccin dipra oui
exactement
les pistes effectivement de vaccins sur
le modèle de l'un des navires us ont été
écartés et on se retrouve effectivement
quelque sorte avec les finalistes dans
la course au vaccin qui pour le moment
donne les meilleurs résultats en termes
de sécurité d'emploi comment gères le
gouvernement ce dossier vaccinale est ce
qu'il est déjà prévu que cela soit
redistribuée dans toute l'europe comme
ça c'est fait d'ailleurs avec les
allemands biotech qui n'ont pas gardé
plus de vaccins pour eux mais ont dû
alors répartir sur tout le territoire
européen ce que c'est la même chose pour
le moment il n'y a pas de stratégie dans
la mesure où les études ne sont pas
encore suffisamment avancé mais ce qui
est certain c'est qu'effectivement il ya
une vraie volonté d'aboutir dans la
fabrication de ces vaccins et qu'en cas
de succès des études et bien
effectivement de telles stratégies
seront à l'ordre du jour une dernière
petite question sur la situation
sanitaire en espagne comment les choses
se passe en espagne aujourd'hui écoutés
l'évolution est favorable les
couvre-feux maintenant on est et vont
être levés
le leurre de couvre-feu a été notamment
élargi en catalogne
donc on est toujours dans ce retour
progressif à la normale dans de bonnes
conditions mais avec une vigilance
toujours particulière sur les
indicateurs épidémiologique
comme tout le monde en europe à merci
philippe emmanuel y avait un français
exerçant en espagne d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france